hi welcome back if i'm shopping it's
from my couch
with my laptop and my sweatpants and my
kids on either side of me
who in that moment are purposefully
chipping away at the bliss i'm trying to
immerse myself in called
retail therapy but that's why i'm
excited that we've teamed up with rue la
la an online store where you can get all
these high quality designer items at
totally different price points
and every once in a while we also get
the privilege of shopping with one of
our friends so
without further ado here now with this
week's hot
rue la la items is my friend kalana
barfield brown
hi drew hi colada
oh i love doing this with you i love
doing this drew we have some
incredible items from rue la la today
starting with this frette plush velour
robe
that i have on i have it on in white you
have it in the rose color
it is so incredible it's so comfortable
and i love
that it's unisex so it's for his or her
um and i love that it also has this
great shawl collar
nice big pockets and the material is so
great
now get this this is normally three
hundred dollars
today we are getting it at 59.99 that's
an 80 discount it really is a stew
frette is a serious company it really is
so if you can get this at that price
that is
incredible it really is a great deal
okay so you and i love to talk about
beauty products we love to talk about
the latest and greatest and what really
works
so today we have this incredible beauty
product it's from
core organics it's their noni glow
sleeping mask
and it's filled with moisturizing
ingredients like coconut milk
it's a clear gel formula you put on
before bed
you wake up rinse your face and it gives
you an instant glow
this is miranda kerr's company it
absolutely is and this
normally is 48 today we're getting it
for 23.99
that's a 50 discount
i'm sorry you can look well rested for
23 dollars
over and over and this is actually a big
bottle
yeah you know and it and it's a i mean i
think a little goes a long way with this
mask
as well this is amazing okay next is
like self-care
on another level it is this you
comfy heated foot massager it really
feels like you have
a foot masseuse at home and right now
it's a very difficult time and you know
certain cities and states have different
restrictions
right also i don't care what times we're
in
it's hard to get out of the house to do
things like this for yourself all right
put your foot in there
ready yes i'm gonna turn it on okay i'm
gonna crank it to like the
oh my god it feels so
good oh my god and i love that you can
adjust
the pressure so if you're someone who
likes a little pressure you got it if
you like
a lot of pressure you got it there's
five different levels there is like
sadistic reflexology happening within my
bubble right now
and i love it i love it this is like
god i have to say that i didn't think
you could get this kind of action from a
machine like that it really is powerful
i love it
it's honestly it's a game changer how
much does this cost
this normally so it normally goes for
299.99
today we are getting it for 110.99
that is a sixty three percent
done this is this i have to say this is
very different than what i would think
yeah guess what baby you and me
right and we have it in two colors we
have it in that red and we also have it
in silver
okay what else do we have that i don't
know
i know it's going to be hard to talk but
last but not least we all need our
comfortable underwear
we have hanky panky low-rise thongs
they are so comfortable it's their
classic stretchy lace material
but we're getting sets of three for a
great price
how much normally these go for 72
dollars for three today we're getting
them at 34.99 that's
a 51 discount i have to admit i've been
wearing a g string under my pants
because i wear like a very full bottom
brief
and i just when i'm in my off time it's
like
you know the baggier the better right
but when i'm at work
i want to try and you know
not have vpl right visible panty lines
this is the thing i don't know what do
you guys have like
butt huggers what's the thing for you
cause women we fret
we really we frettay
the reason hanky-panky got so famous was
because they are like a non-vpl visible
pantyline situation
and these are beautiful they're really
and they're comfortable they're
comfortable
that's the other thing we need that and
i will say these are the most
famous in underwear yeah they really are
so to get them
at this price point is honestly like a
steal and we have so many different
prints and patterns
i mean i will say too in all earnestness
it is hard for us uh to carve out this
time for ourselves
it is this is self-care this is
luxuriating
yep and i think it's like worth an
investment and when you're getting it at
a deal it makes it even
greater for all of you at home you can
find these items at rue la la dot com
slash the drewberry moore show
or jewel law as we're saying and
remember these deals are only available
while supplies last so grab them cheers
cheers
and uh we'll be right back
you